can I mention how much I love this hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to error 54
all right let's what do you got for me
[Music]
okay oh this is legit isn't it oh this
is for real okay Oh visions a little
swirly press G dad to inventory all
right
oh that's powerful light okay it's not
nearly as powerful as I thought it's
still dark
I was weird
okay so we're going big spook hours are
we oh it's big spooky time baby pulling
into big spooky Tom Junction okay I'm
down I'm down to Klump
yeah I'm down to clown with this now the
vision is just a little weird
am I crazy or is it like pulsing in and
out at random and also everything seems
really dream sequence like what what I
could have sworn I just saw like eyes at
back of that hallway but I'm crazy
what's happening oh no oh it's Petey
oh this is Petey Oh way notes
why is everything backwards
I see I see I see I see all right
oh not everything's backwards only some
things are backwards only that run back
there's whoa my sprint is fast all right
okay
okay it was then always there I don't
remember that one but okay I'm guessing
that there's gonna be nothing in these
cabinets I'm just guessing well I don't
like this
I'm just trying all the doors Oh in case
they change I didn't expect that well
then I guess we got a problem okay
broken Lantern was added to inventory
where's my inventory do I need to worry
about my inventory I'm not gonna worry
about my inventory cyber crime the
latest news for day a dangerous virus
has rapidly captured hundreds of
thousands of devices around the world
American telecommunications they
accompany Jane Fariq has warned users
about the act of spreading a malicious
software called number 54 this virus has
infected hundreds of thousands of
computers and this number is growing
exponentially information security
experts claim that this virus collects
all possible information about the user
and transmitted to the creator London
and Washington accused Russia of
spreading the virus the Creator the
Creator who is the creator
I thought I heard like breathing okay
okay yeah yeah sure okay yeah yeah okay
this all makes sense this is all Gucci
this is great this is good first you son
of a [ __ ] everything is incredibly fine
was that me please tell me that was me
I really hope beyond hope that that was
me oh my goodness oh my goodness oh my
goodness I don't like this I don't like
this at all what was that
what was that noise
we're fine keys keys I got keys great
love keys I don't think so I do not
think so oh there's nobody there
great good this is fantastic I love
everything about this this is great this
game is great
Oh someone knocked over the radio
that's great also great okay stop what
squeaking squeaking can I will smack you
oh oh are those the keys I just used cuz
that was convenient but also I don't
know why I needed that still dark huh
still dark okay
okay this is fine oh good you're open
now I was hoping I was hoping you would
be open hoping you do was that me
breathing I'm gonna assume that was me
breathing in the city of Portland
residents reported the loss of
well-known video bloggers having on the
channel more than a hundred thousand
subscribers on the channel bloggers
shared how to fix various system errors
and get rid of viruses it is known that
the blogger at the time of the
kidnapping was at home and filmed
another video tutorial and even managed
to save the file called how to fix
number 54 system error the search has
already begun and then youtuber with
many hundreds of thousands of
subscribers who recorded video of Jame
54 freaking frick frick frick frick
frick
goes missing very mysteriously
[Applause]
[Music]
whoo ohh whoo ohh whoo ohh whoo ohh whoo
ohh whoo
this is fine oh no oh no oh no oh no oh
no I'm gonna close this door and when I
open it again everything's gonna be
Gucci everything is gonna be super Gucci
Gucci duty yep just as I was way too me
[Music]
my back was just up against that okay oh
good oh good oh good oh oh good good
good
in fact good the only word that I would
use to describe the scenario is good oh
good another note why I don't know don't
have any idea can't escape here we go
here we go well why why why why I don't
know why I actually do not know but sure
it's fine okay okay okay all right yeah
okay all right okay
some backrooms [ __ ] going on here
there's something on it I'm gonna go
this way
gotta go this way and everything will be
fine don't gotta go this way okay and
then everything will be fine great
everything's fine
well
right and sunshiny in here huh Brian
sunshine great good good so great so
great so great actually the greatest I'd
say the best this is great I love this
can I mention how much I love this fine
this is great this so cool it's fine
it's good so good so good thought I
heard a noise behind me I might have
been in the game
how are you doing how are you doing how
are you doing okay yeah that's just
icing on the cake there you didn't need
to do that okay okay all right
oh look behind you oh I shouldn't looked
I shouldn't have looked
I should have known I should have
guessed oh good it's awful I mean this
is great this is fine your booby trap
almost got me but I'm just too clever by
I can't go through here so I guess I'll
go back the way I came
oh good and no great I was hoping for
one of these do you want to play what
about hide-and-seek you're hiding oh
well then that's fascinating
[Music]
hey guess I lose your it wanna plant
Seco if you're hiding okay good you
gonna do it again oh yeah I'm coming for
you yeah yeah whatever whatever whatever
loser where am I going oh god I mean the
wall okay alright I think I'm doing this
wrong a few ways so you're there
aha there we go there we go there we go
this way this way this way this way ah
flashlight yeah that's important okay
there's no cybercrime the latest news
from today epidemic of dangerous
computer virus moves to a new level
yesterday the virus named 54 CS to all
the electronic billboards in Tokyo and
demonstrated the startling inscription
you were next to save the city from this
inscription could only one way power off
the damage caused by the most massive
cyberattack is estimated at tens of
millions of dollars the city authorities
are furious great great that's good
that's good that's good stuff good stuff
good solution power off the whole city
huh couldn't have powered off the
billboard or something the whole city
okay okay all right
oh hey I did it I did it I made it out I
made it out of the maze and a free
the 54 virus is the biggest threat to
the global economy over the past two
days hundreds of millions of people have
complained about their banks for stolen
money and completely zeroed out cash
accounts the damage is estimated at more
than 10 billion dollars as strange as it
may sound
many now do not advise to use the
Internet at all because of virus 54
doesn't sound very strange I'm sure
people complied I'm sure of it oh god no
what are you in this what are you doing
what are you doing what are you doing
what are you doing are you doing what
are you doing
leave this place I'm trying
you see that's what I'm trying to do hi
okay you know what actually I'm gonna
leave oh that's not good what's this Oh
right great
I didn't see the keys didn't see the
keys keys right there I see him I see
him got him
easy peasy easy peasy easy keys easy
keys keys these Keys got the keys easy
well then oh don't like that no that's
not good that's not good at all
no God I don't have hope keys I see I
see my see give give give give give it's
right there gift yes gift gift oh my god
did I make it
oh god I didn't make it did I mark
that's normal
oh that's not good
Oh
[Music]
that was I think we can all agree easily
one of the scariest games I've played
that was terrifying the pacing was
spot-on like I died a few times but the
lead-up to it was so well done that's it
god that was good
wherever the developer is here I don't
even know if it says who made this
someone by the name achillea IQ yeah
that was good I really like that that's
all I can say so thank you everybody so
much for watching if you want to play
this for yourself
links in the description but man that
was really terrifying
I loved it though so thanks again if you
want to see more scary games that I've
played I'll put them in the description
below or there in the suggested videos
over there if you enjoyed this leave a
like if you want to see more scary games
subscribe to the channel ring the bell
if you want to know when videos are
coming out and thanks again and as
always I'll see you
bye-bye
[Music]